you know that they need to update
anybody on oh there's councelor Rock now
okay um then we'll move on to the next
one which is to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 9th of January
confirm the minutes first and then we'll
go on to matters arising um are you
happy with the the actual minutes
anybody want to um propose the
minutes y uh and I'll second them so are
you all happy that the the minutes be
accepted the matters arising the was um
that's 3A uh anybody got any questions
that they want to ask about the matters
arising from from
uh
yeah
um mentioned the the community being set
up St just yeah but um it won't come
into matters arising it come or will it
yeah okay in that case uh matters
arising please update us on the climate
Hub just let me just go through the so
it's
the
uh I can't remember exactly where it was
but please just update us
okay right I think I've managed to work
this microphone so uh hopefully you can
hear me um so we have um as as you know
I've been looking for a a building in
the Town Center for a long time to turn
into a climate Hub with the idea that
one of the best things for climate
action and for climate communication is
to have a physical space in the very
core of the town where you know anyone
walking by will will encounter this
rather than just encountering you know
the actions and issues on websites which
are rather optional um and you don't
necessarily you know experience it as
part of your your daily life uh we have
now signed a lease for a year it's a
mean lease so we in theory can be turfed
out with 20day notice but we don't think
that's going to happen the landlord um
has you know for for his own reasons
it's likely we'll be in there for a year
he's he's appealing a uh an application
that's going to take a year basically
and it's not worth him getting anyone in
there in the meantime so because of what
he's thinking about it is likely we will
be there for you know nearly a year a
year you know around that um so we have
this building on me street it's number
30 me street if you know the street it's
you know it's just down from where the
citizens advice Bureau used to be um it
it was Edwards a state agent if you if
you knew that um we've got the
downstairs shop shop area and also two
upstairs um floors which are a bit more
spacious because it carries over an arch
so we've got um shop space and we've got
office space uh we've got a good shop
window and the downstairs space will be
a space where which we can use
for for for a kind of dropin Center so
people can come in there'll be
information up we'll have activities on
there we'll be looking to get people in
for specific activ activities as well as
having General activities there we'll
have computer displays we'll have
interactive um games or interactive um
programs um and we'll have you know
artwork it'll hopefully be nice we won't
be having we won't be installing
specialist coffee um system there's
enough coffee shops in the town already
but we will be able to offer people a
cup of tea
um we also will have um upstairs office
space um potentially meeting room
although accessibility is an issue so
you know we've only got one flight of
stairs and we don't have a elevator or
anything so if anyone's got
accessibility issues then you know
there's limits to how we can get people
up there but we have um office space up
there we'll be looking at doing some
co-working there so we might be hiring
rooms out to people we might also just
be doing some hot desking for you know
Specialists who are involved in climate
climate uh related um issues people
working in various relevant
organizations so we might set up you
know a kind of co-working um events
where people in that same area can come
and work together but also talk to each
other in the in the breaks in the day um
so that's one thought but one thing um
in particular that I'd like to we'd like
to do is to use it as a space to display
Council actions Council activities
Council action plans potentially in the
form of maps but you know potentially in
any form um so I just want to come along
and just you know raise the issue let
councilors be aware of this and ask the
council to think about how you would
like to present some of the things
you're doing do you want to develop some
specific
leaflets um we still need to look at the
space that's available for this so
poster space how much space is there for
specific things there's a lot of
competing um you know information we
could potentially put up there but you
know there might be space for posters
for computer programs things like that
so yeah I just want to put that out
there how would the council like to
present some of the things it's doing to
the public and how would you like us to
get back to you I'd be very interested
in but and one thing that occurred to me
was we are going to be doing something
with big green week and it's something
that may be uh just being able to Pro
promote the fact that we you know the
there are we won't be the only
organization that's doing that the RSC
and various other bodies um but again
it's just promoting um please do
continue to have conversations with
Offices here at the district council I I
you know it's something that we may be
able to build on you know month by month
uh I mean obviously if you were there
for more than a year we we you know even
longer to build on um but yeah we we'll
see what you know it's exciting times
that you know you can get you can get to
people you know I noticed that for
example when we do work in in oler um we
get to people that the council can never
really get to uh and uh and that you
know yeah and of interest and that would
be and then could we also ask that
Lessons Learned in a way come back
because if we ever want to um support uh
anybody else that's going to do this
wherever in the district they are um you
know we'd love to learn the kind of
lessons and yeah you know how difficult
it was but what you actually did would
be really interesting councelor Rock
you've got your hand up uh thank thank
you thank you chair can I be
heard yes you are and yeah and just an
idea in response to the speaker didn't
quite catch everything uh but um it it
it does occur to me chair we we could
readily
produce uh posters and Graphics um
through our Graphics team uh reflecting
the actions we've got um within our work
plan uh and and particularly how people
can apply to the climate change fund or
albeit we're we're on the first TR of
that now and what we proposing to do uh
with investigating you know the various
things we've we've got on the stocks you
know clearly the the headline thing is
is what we doing with u uh the waste
trucks but um there's a list of things
that we're doing and I'm sure we we
could readily produce those Graphics
that that would help the the Ambiance in
in the facility as well because we I
think we're pretty good at producing
things that are have got a nice
appearance as
well thank you for that um we'll we'll
we'll approach offices it will obviously
be up to capacity um but um you know I
think whatever we can do we we we'll try
our best to do you know what we can so
thank you for that update is there are
there any other updates um Manuel do you
want to kind of come in at this stage
and then counsel Trump as
well thank you ch um and thank you
Stephen for coming to um tell us about
this exciting initiative I think it's um
it's important for you to be here and
kind of continue to build a partnership
with um local authorities um in in the
commun you know to to contribute to the
community Hub and I wonder whether when
is the open um day of of the Hub and
whether the climate change panel could
come and have um and and visit um the
the you know the kind of physical Hub
and and meet
volunteers um well I think at the moment
we're talking about opening to the
public at the end of this month maybe
the start of the next but I mean once
we've got a few posters up which will be
next couple of days you know we might be
you know we we'll see when we feel ready
to invite you guys in but you know we're
we're already inviting some people in to
give out their ideas and just look
around the space
so I think you know if we're talking
about working together and getting you
know some of your graphics and so on in
there you know we'd be happy to show you
around a bit sooner than public opening
so we'll be in touch about that and if I
bring in councelor cruma then councelor
petravic um okay yeah really good it's
very positive again I think if we can
sign post to one another's organizations
um to to help one another and get the
message across to as many people as
possible about all the services
available and you did say you got the
cattle already so when the climate
change panel came would be okay for a
cup of tea was that okay yes that's
[Laughter]
fine councel
pet thank you chair and thank you
Stephen so so much for coming and and
sharing all of the update and just a
quick question for me in terms of the
program of activities and um obviously
there's already so much that NetZero is
doing I was just wondering if you
already have any ideas uh for
collaboration working with other
organizations um in addition to
obviously the the
council yeah um quite a few I I would
really like to get the the um Eco groups
from the schools involved so I'll be
talking to them um other local groups
that are involved in the climate area
obviously we'll be talking to them um
we'll we'll probably be looking for
sponsorships so uh they've been
developing a bit of a list of of people
sorry my threat's gone a bit um one um
I think in terms of the the the um
display we'll probably be having a cycle
of of activ of um you know of months so
month monthly displays um local artists
art groups will probably be working with
them one possible theme for the um
display will be on food which we've
talked about in the past so it would be
really good to meet up again at some
point if we decide we're going to do
that and and go over what you're doing
what we can display in the window
and I'm sure you'll have contacts that
you can give to us to to help with that
as well so and and yeah and other
suggestions I suppose act on energy we
work with them um yeah the list is long
so uh but the idea is to get as many
organizations involved as
possible thank you very much on the
other matters of arising uh does anybody
want to raise any of the others I mean
I'd just like to say thank you um to
Ellie for for all the work she's done uh
particularly on getting the climate
change uh funded up and running and uh
you know so many of the other things
that are on there she's she's worked
incredibly hard uh so you know that and
we've got the um big green week is is is
an agenda item uh is there anything else
that you want to
raise we go go here we go um could you
update us on the uptake of the climate
change and also any idea when the next
round may may come
about just just having um the the
technology
coming
hang on just a
minute okay no yeah there we go um yeah
we've had a really good uptake for the
climate change fund we've had 27
successful expressions of Interest so um
they have been invited to submit full
applications which we've set a deadline
for the middle of April um all
applicants have also been sent some kind
of resources and alternative funds as
well because we are over subscribed so
um
themed themed packs basically that say
for their particular theme what
community other community funds are
available to try and kind of
maximize um the kind of reach of it so
yeah we've had a really good uptake it's
been really successful um in in terms of
when the next round will take place I
don't know um I suppose that
conversation is probably one to be had
over the next couple of months as we
kind of um go through the process
because obviously we've still got to get
the full applications in appraise them
and everything and then we'll probably
regroup on that then but yeah really
good response I think we're all really
really happy with kind of um kind of the
reach that we've had with
it and it should be really good to get
kind of get some feedback from the first
Tran as well and make sure that um the
process you know whether the process can
be improved and what lessons can be
learned um but it it's really you know I
think the the ones that I've heard about
uh cover quite a scope from quite small
projects to some very ambitious projects
so um it would be really interesting to
see what comes uh I can't remember who
came first but councelor Crump and
councelor Petrovic are in that order
probably is is the what I can see on the
on the
screen thank you for that that the
oldest one go first so that's that's
really helpful um the uh one thing that
councelor Curtis red that um I think it
was the cabinet not the one gone the one
before um about the U matters arising
and it was to do and I agree with him
when I think I've rais the point as well
it's to do with the the time scales
associated with some of the projects and
and some I totally understand that they
are quite flexible and we still things
are being developed if we can get some
time scale or indicative time scale of
when these things are going to take
place that's going to be helpful for us
as counselors to to tell our residents
uh and the point about the second trch
of the climate trans TR fund uh is is
going to be helpful as well so if the
people um haven't been able to been
successful can apply again on new people
and and any idea how much it was over
subscribed by you know will we putting
$50,000 dat and we've had £ 150,000
worth of applications again um if it's
not available if that could be found and
distributed to the rest of the panel to
later date that will be helpful thank
you yeah I'm happy for the next panel to
bring a bit of a kind um summary paper
if that would help with the themes and
how much we really subscribed by and
that kind of detail um in reference to
the timelines we're going to be looking
at getting a strategy together over the
next couple of months um with more
specific timing for kind of all the work
streams that are going on across the
council with climate change and the
environment as a focus so again as
anything happens in that space you'll be
kept up to
date um councelor pet and then councelor
Manuela
pel thank you CH just a quick followup
on the climate change fund um I was just
wondering whether there is a deadline
for when the projects need to be
delivered that are successful and then
the second question was around the
another matter Rising um the response to
the
uh climate action
scorecard um and whether that is
something that we will be responding to
um and I know that in the agenda it says
that it's May 2024 expect is that when
the deadline is or that's when we need
to have a decision on whether we are
looking to reply or not are you happy to
answer that one straight away yeah
that's fine um sorry councelor petrovich
can you repeat your first question I've
forgotten that got the scard sorry there
two different oh the deadline about the
fund uh so yeah for the projects deliver
so successful projects do they have a
timeline uh for when for until when do
they have the funds for and if there's a
deadline for when they need to deliver
the project by that that was the end of
the 2025 Financial year so 2425 and that
was to allow at least two seasons of
tree planting so that if we do get any
successful tree planting projects
through they have the opportunity this
autumn and winter to make sure that
they've got everything that they need to
have in place before they can deliver
that so it's to try and make sure that
they have plenty of time um the score
cards we haven't heard as of yet I think
that the deadline for the right to apply
for last year was the 15th of May so I
think we've expected that the deadline
for the right to apply will be the same
again but we've I haven't heard anything
as of yet and they're usually pretty
good at getting in touch and giv a heads
up as to when that's going to happen so
no progress has been made on that as of
yet C Council
pugel H this was this is just an
observation on the on some of the
projects um what the in my W uh one
particular project I tried to apply and
Ellie is aware of that it's
um there is this conflict between um you
know new green in technology and uh you
know retrofitting and solar panels and
planning um regulations in conservation
areas so um and it was the specific case
of a village Joel um wanted to explore
solar panels but in a Conservation Area
uh they will probably need to apply for
uh either a lawful development
certificate or uh planning application
or a full planning application so
obviously that's added um Financial
issues before then they apply to the CL
you know they they they apply to the
climate change um fund so that's
something just to keep in mind that um
we have this I would say maybe conflict
in some in some in some area especially
when we talk about solar panels and
conservation areas and I don't know how
um we can support um our um our village
olds in that in that way thank you I
think these are the kind of some of the
issues that we need to pick up as a as
part of a report of about uh why some
things were went through some things
didn't why some things were successful
maybe some Le less so we need that we
need to pick up those kind of Lessons
Learned uh as as we go through now
moving on we've got the um big green
week unless has anybody got anything
else on any of the other matches arising
uh issues on the from the last agenda we
go forward onto the number four which is
the Big Green weed and that's just to
kind of have an update on the Big Green
week that is being planned for
2024 um do do we um do you want to kind
of do this or or is it um the counselors
that are involved yeah counsel hatch and
and councelor hatch and councelor per
are you able to just kind of have a
quick update on how how far and what
you're actually you know how far you've
gone and what actually you're doing and
planning
um do do you want to go first manueller
and then I'll fill in if uh yeah shall I
shall I just uh just a summary so
obviously as as matters arising also
also point out um we we're still looking
for volunteers from this lovely panel um
to help us with uh the event uh so the
the stfo district council uh um LED
event facilitated event is still a
community event but will be facilitated
by St District Council is wrapping up um
the uh great big green week and it's
going to happen on the 5th of
July uh and uh from and it will be the
full day from uh 10: to 5: uh there is
also uh a a climat related event at the
RC so Olivia and I are going to meet
with the RC next week to see how we can
collaborate so we'll we'll come back um
at the next panel and um possibly be
able to present a final uh draft of the
program and is um is really about uh
local engagement um and and we'll
conclude in a way the great big green
week um we'll mark also this this event
will mark five years since straf
District Council declared the climate
emergency I think that was July
2019 and so uh we hope they will
showcase progress and plans uh residents
can also feedback on on the on the uh
climate change plan and also uh best
practice in the district um and we look
forward also to further actions
involving everyone and of course uh um
you know now the CL the climate Hub as
well um hopefully will be um part of
that and be referred so the main aims
are to promot OTE Community engagement
with action for climate and nature
across the district including schools to
Prov to provide a springboard for more
action and also to to Showcase local
best practice and of course perhaps some
of the receivers of the community uh
climate change fund might want to come
and and um and show um what they're
doing um and is going to be structured
uh with uh with the plary uh there's
going to be exhibition stalls as well so
we are in discussions with various
stakeholders and Community groups and
and other tiers of government and then
we will have um the the will have
different workshops which in a way
reflect the the main areas of the
climate change council plan um and uh
Olivia would you like to talk a little
bit about the the areas that we're going
to uh explore yeah
so
sorry the so the the the workshops that
we've um outlined um cover business food
energy and
housing biodivers and River Health
Community Action climate adaptation
waste transport and
schools um so I think that covers all
the areas that the district have and I
know they don't have influence over
transport but so we're hoping to get
somebody from the County Council and
obviously we have influence over active
travel um and so the idea is that
members of the community could book on
to each of these these different
workshops and they'd all each be an hour
long um and there would be an officer or
some decision maker in each Workshop so
the the plenary at the end will have
some discussion what has come out of the
workshops and hopefully a spring board
for some more action so that's where
we've got to at the moment but as as
Mano said we we we need to um we need to
combine with with the RSC so we haven't
got anything in Perman in in pen yet and
just to kind of update other members of
the of the committee that the two
councilors have had a had a meeting with
u the deputy chief executive and with
Ellie as the climate change officer um
so uh they've all been kept informed and
the date is booked it's in my diary uh
and I I'm I'm volunteering to help on
the day okay so that's an update and
please keep us informed um because time
will pass quite quickly uh and uh we we
really got to there's a lot to deliver
it's already March and uh that that's
not too far now to to July Manuel
Council
per yes so um we're hoping to bring the
final uh the program the final kind of
structure to the next um uh panel um and
we will share it obviously before with
the with the with the members but if
anyone of you has an interest in a
particular area that councelor hch has
just uh um named listed come and uh talk
to us and um uh we can we can then um
allocate you to that area and you you
will be able to help and assist on the
day thank you and Council
Petra thank you CH H yeah so I just
wanted to put my hand up I've already
spoken to councelor hatch but I would um
be very pleased to
shair the workshop on
food thank you very much everybody um
that's that's good to see that it's all
coming together uh just we say all bear
in mind I you know that time flows very
very fast so you know we just need to
keep keep the pressure on and and get it
all all fully arranged and and because
um you need to advertise you need to
give lots of time for people to get it
into their Diaries so uh please uh I
thank you very much and um moving
forward um next item is the fresh food
strategy for Stratford and South
warshire and we're going to have a PR
presentation here uh from rosemary Kia
from war Crop Center on the local fresh
food strategy welcome uh to this panel
and I look forward to your presentation
over to you m uh
Rosemary thank you very much um so
actually I'm passing it over to my
colleague Richard napia because I wasn't
sure I was going to be here this
afternoon um um so he's prepared or
we've prepared something uh that
Richard's going to
deliver okay Richard but you over to you
for your presentation yeah so I've got a
few slides I'm going to share uh share
now um
and hopefully you can see
that we can see that and and it would be
appreciated also if we if we can have
maybe copies afterwards it would be
would be appreciated as well yes of
course we can send copies in that's no
problem um so yes you've just read out
the title of our project this U arose
because uh Rosemary uh met with uh some
of your colleagues there councelor hatch
and Petrovic uh and at the same time a
small amount of money became available
within University with the regional in
infrastructure fund so we put in for
this project and it's run out of our war
Crop Center which is at the Stratford
Innovation campus um so it was suggested
that we just give a little I know some
of you know the campus quite well
wellsborne Horticultural research
international all sorts of different
names it's had in the past so
um yeah I was there I was there this
morning and and I know the war Crop
Center and the HRI um well because I I
used to work in crop genetics so I'm
really looking forward to
this yes so so we've been there since
1949 so this year is our 75th
anniversary and we'll be inviting you
all to come and see us on one of our
open days also in July actually um later
uh I'm sure that invitation will be will
be put together so uh for those who
don't know it quite so well
um our science has evolved with the
times and of course these are the
current areas of of expertise where we
have science ongoing around uh around
the site War around War crops Center and
of course within the rest of the
University of
Warick um all of these listed there and
I don't need need to spell them all out
all of these of course are changing as
rapidly as the climate and with the
climate and so there's a relevance to
what we do on food food production
particularly on vegetables of course uh
that resonates with the with the
activities that your net zero plans are
going forward with and so it's it's it's
Serendipity I think that things came
together at the the right time so that
we can perhaps help you for some useful
policies uh and in a well-informed
scientific way so as well as these very
much science-based
interests uh we uh have uh on on site
the United Kingdom vegetable genan bank
so this keeps an enormous repository of
natural variation that crosses our major
vegetable Commodities so that's a
nationally uh funded uh resource that's
that's on site funded by
defra one of our newer activities uh is
war Agri Tech and you can see a picture
of of a robot
spraying some plants on the on the right
over there um and war agch is a new
Fusion of an interests between us in the
Crop Center and wmg which is a part of
our engineering school and of course
they have been uh enormously reinforced
by the activities working with Jaguar
Land Rover Tata steel and so on in the
past and they bring that enormous
repertoire of expertise from the
automotive Industries which the West
Midlands are so good at but they're now
saying let's have let's have a go
agriculture let's see if we can help
take take our robots out of a factory
and into the field so we're very keen to
be working with them on that and and
that should help us a great deal and
then really where we're relevant to this
community today is that Rosemary and I
in particular are looking at how we can
influence food policy in the country uh
particularly with our focus on the
expertise in fruit and vegetables or
fresh produce so that brings us very
nicely to the project that we're working
on now uh
and uh this is H as I said it was it was
a short project uh it the opportunity
arose at very very short notice and so
it may not have been the most perfectly
formed but I think it will work very
well um towards the Ambitions of the of
the council here so we aim to identify
summarize and analyze information that
will underpin the development of a fresh
food strategy for Stratford paven
district and South
warshire and you can see I've already
mentioned I and and Ley are helping us
but we've al already had an enormous
amount of help actually from a number of
different counselors uh including Ellie
who's sitting beside you there and
that's been really useful because we
know there's a lot of information that
we didn't have before but you did and of
course there's no point recreating that
um so what we're also aware of is that
you all already have a number of policy
or strategy documents and again we
didn't want to recreate or change these
unnecessarily they're listed on the on
the left there there's an your Economic
Development strategy your Net Zero
strategy the warsha food strategy and
and so on uh but what we have done is
we've mapped the Ambitions of our
project against these and so perhaps the
most important one is that pink one top
right uh we hope that what we'll be able
to do is to help you increase local
access to an consumption of fresh food
and I should say at this point that
fresh food although I've mentioned fruit
and veget vegetables for this particular
project we're also looking at primary
production Farm production so so uh
animal production poultry production um
as as well as fruit and vegetables and
and arable so all the primary areas just
because it would be it it would be
incomplete not to map them all um so
opposite to that lower left of course
we'd like to increase the production of
fresh food which leads to that one at
the bottom we want to look at it trying
to improve local employment
opportunities uh and and all of these
hopefully will be in a way that's
informed so that we make a positive
impact on the on Net Zero towards the
effects of climate
change uh we also want to of course at
the top there enhance rural Landscapes
and biodiversity so uh hopefully that's
that's a positive sign on the on on on
your on your side that we're working in
the right
direction so these then are the
activities that we wrote into our
project plan and I have to say they do
map quite closely retrospectively as it
happens because uh we had to write this
very very fast but on onto your policy
documents your strategy documents at
least so we're going to map the
distributions of producers and consumers
of fresh food in the region taking into
account access to food and food
insecurity which I know you already do
quite a lot
on uh map jobs and other opportunities
in the Fresh Food Industries as well as
the support structures for
them uh we're going to of course
Benchmark these against other Regional
and national projects which have
developed food
strategies um and look to whether or not
there's a reasonable scope for setting
up a localized food system whatever that
might look like or perhaps informing
what that might look
like and then a part of the project
which is with WG with usme group the
small medium priz Enterprise Group
Business Development Group within WG um
there is an accelerator scheme of
mentoring local businesses to to try and
encourage those new people into into the
uh fresh food production industries or
at Le help them build their build their
businesses together and of course we'll
report at the
end so just this is just to show how
well we think the project Maps against
some of the priorities around the county
already the bit in green there uh is is
one of your uh sustainable choice
priorities uh so and this of course
brings us directly to climate change
which we had we didn't focus on WE
focused on fresh food strategy but of
course this does map across to how we we
address uh some of these climate change
uh issues so uh we have those objectives
there that what we do hopefully will
lead to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
for example and support
biodiversity so just two slides then on
the sorts of data we've collected
already um so we have a lot of data from
you uh and other sources National
sources from defra and the office of
national
statistics and uh so we know how many
people live here we know their age
brackets and we've also mapped onto that
what the ideal diet healthy diet would
look like um and that's taken into
account children that eat differently
than than adults and so on and so this
little graph that's put in here shows in
red uh what those recommended daily
needs are are for the best healthy diet
and as we all know we don't eat enough
fruit and vegetables uh and we eat too
much meat because the blue bars there
are what we actually currently
purchase so but for milk it's more
balanced so we'll collect more data like
that and then we're looking at where all
these things are produced uh you know
how much there is in the region this is
in the Stratford area but you can see
there a map in the bottom right hand
side here um
that uh is the area that we're
considering which is that definition of
local food which is 30 miles and we've
just taken a central point uh of the
warshire uh warer South warshire area to
to Center that 30 uh 30 mile radius
circle on so that little map there
already is plotting the the register
Dairy Producers in the region and of
course we can do that for for we will be
doing that for many many other types of
primary producers so we'll know when
where everything is produced and whether
that can inform for example where
forestry might go well who knows that's
something for us still to
determine and then uh on the on the
other side uh We've course looked at
jobs um the graph here without reading
all the details details on the data we
have here the graph is showing that
fewer people are being employed in the
agriculture sector uh although the the
data was quite flat to start with it's
definitely Lo we've lost people people
employed in the agriculture sector over
the last two years U and we've also lost
the number of businesses that are
registered in agriculture we would like
to see this reverse or at least to
stabilize to reverse and so some of our
our work will be going into how we can
support that and part of that will be
this accelerator scheme uh which we're
working on with the
wmg so that's that's a summary of Where
we've got up to now I kept it brief so
you can ask questions we have a if you
want to ask any more questions put other
people in contact we've Rosemary will be
our primary point of contact UM at the
Stratford Innovation campus um and uh
and I'll stop there for now well thank
you very much I I've got lots of
questions um about how we can U link
together for example we recently had uh
the ruro shared Prosperity fund and um
uh it um we didn't we it was difficult
getting some people to to apply um but
we're trying to advertise more but it it
did occur to me that for example um
small farm shops um you know that that
small businesses could be uh funded
through that and there are other schemes
as well so we can link in not only what
you doing but also take it further
through that kind of Route um there
there is a lot of a lot of um um that
that we could do with with Parish
councils that have allotments we've got
um Community Orchards we got got
community fridges um we you know that um
it's not only what you want to do now
but we can we can link in to other other
uh actions as well so I'm really excited
by what you what you've outlined and I
do hope um you know we can get something
really good going from it uh I've got
councelor Crump and then counselor Rock
who want to ask
questions yeah I'm say thank you for
this is really really positive really
interesting one thing obviously lotss of
people are still struggling with the
cost of living and buying food and
buying fresh food and we often see in
supermarkets where there are special
offers it's normally on chocolate or
things that are relatively unhealthy
says says the person who's really got
Sweet Tooth and I have to be careful
what I eat um so I think if we can try
and
um work with with schools communities uh
and try and get as much fresh fruit uh
fruit and veg into into people's diet um
sometimes um working with communities
the allotments societies and things like
that I think that's really positive and
and I do think the the positive benefits
of allotments of for particularly for
men's mental health is is really really
positive so um yeah I think it's a long
winded way of of trying to make how we
can get the appropriate diet especially
for young people
to people that's affordable or bearing
in mind the cost of living crisis and we
know like you say farming people I've
got quite a raw area my County Ward and
we know that people are not going into
it because it's not not considered um to
be for one to better phrase attractive I
can't think of a better phrase but I
think you know what I mean um so yeah
just some thoughts on that please that
um I think we we do need to people do
realize the benefits but sometimes it's
theice choice of buying some uh food
that is cheaper but relatively unhealthy
uh and then they can potentially pay for
their heating sort of thing slight
extreme example but I think you get
where I'm come from an apologies for
long question okay if I bring in uh
councelor Rock and then I'll bring in uh
Rosemary uh to to perhaps wrap up some
of th those questions and what she's
heard from myself as well councelor Rock
uh thanks very much well I'm involved
with the southw it's your local plan
uh which is a forward-looking document
and and and your last few points um
alluded to the sort of a drop off of
activity in the agricultural sector uh I
don't think I'm giving any secrets away
to to say well the southw your plan
making like all planning making is
horribly complicated huge amount of data
trying to be pulled together and to
filter it down but at the last meeting
it was pointed out we're working on away
through housing numbers we're working
away through amount of Economic
Development land you know which
generally speaking is is manufacturing
warehousing and all this sort of thing
but the point was made is well we've got
an agricultural area as well what are we
doing about that and it occurs to me uh
that you've probably done quite a bit of
work which uh it would be helpful to
collaborate with our policy team on um
uh and that there may be a mutual
benefit here because you have got some
data about the trends in agriculture and
land use uh which we could draw upon and
um possibly help in in the South waru
local plan to avoid that a lot of
farming and we've got Innovative
techniques coming along which statford
district might be able to lead on uh and
if we could leverage that through those
activities so I think if officers could
help uh put you in touch with our policy
team and we get a bit of a collaboration
going there uh you know it's early days
in this particular aspect so I think we
we've got an opportunity to do something
so um I don't know how we do that chair
but um if we could get officers to be
talking uh to this team I think that
would be really useful okay if I bring
in R Kia next um and then I'll come to
pet afterwards if you don't mind okay
thank you chair um so I mean I put my
hand up to respond to your um your
comments about collaboration but
actually they're relevant to what
councelor rock has just said as well and
I think for a discussion about policy
need to involve um I guess organizations
that that can um bring in producers
potential producers and and look off
them so um the warshire rural Hub is is
certainly a body that could maybe
facilitate assist with that and also the
the national Farmers Union and the local
branch who have been helping us already
with this study so so I think they need
to be involved in the in the discussion
um I mean with regard to I guess the the
issues around people's preferences or
not for fresh produce and the price of
fresh produce it's it's an incredibly
complicated topic and it is a I mean
it's it's part of a national debate and
Al although you know you wouldn't
believe it there is also a national
debate at the moment about um how badly
a lot of the fresh produce companies are
doing and some of them are leaving um
the area so Orchards food production
things like that so there there is uh
you know that there are certainly things
that can be discussed at a local level
but there is also this big National
debate at the moment um which hasn't
been
resolved yes indeed sorry Rosemary sorry
Rosemary for asking another question I
I'll bring in councelor first and then
councelor I'll come on to you afterwards
okay thank you chair I would um really
like to thank both Richard and rosemary
for this wonderful presentation and all
the work that their team has um done so
far on this and I just wanted to kind of
um Echo what councelor rock was saying
and um maybe just refer to the fact that
we have actually uh spoken to uh Ellie
and she's been really helpful in trying
to direct us to the right uh areas that
could potentially help us incorporate
some of these findings into the South
work your local plan so I don't know ell
don't want to put you on the spot but um
just wanted to maybe see if if you could
share uh what some of those mechanisms
might be and what we might kind of do
with the findings once the Project's
finalized in in March um Ellie do you
want to come in up yeah I can do um just
to say when I got in touch with planning
policy I think there was a staffing
change um so it might be worth me
getting back in touch with them this
week um I think the initial thought was
bit kind of broadly around what
councilor Rock was saying about the
importance of kind of embedding any data
and any kind of findings of the strategy
within the local plan but obviously that
would need the um involvement of
development to kind of say what would be
the best mechanism for that so if I get
back in touch with planning policy this
week and then we can kind of go from
there with it but yeah I agree it's
important to collaborate yeah I mean as
climate change uh starts to hit some of
the uh Heritage um materials the the
seeds and fruits that you have uh at HRI
are going to become increasingly uh
useful and um perhaps uh if we can
spread you know about some about some of
those Heritage I've got Heritage apple
trees in my garden but I'd like to be
able to kind of make sure that other
people know about them uh and other uh I
love the old um some of the Heritage
carrots and I used to work on potato
species was my my speciality which is
probably not quite so exciting as
carrots and and apples uh but just being
able to make sure because um as as uh
the climate changes they're going to
become more and more valuable so and and
I think some people are quite interested
in in growing those um you know across
across the area maybe some Farms Farms
are going to have to adapt the what they
grow quite rapidly in the next 10 to 20
years uh councelor
Pella yes I would like to thank Richard
and rosemary as well for coming to
present me um to us this important
project and I also wanted to highlight
that uh councelor Petrovic and I have
submitted a motion uh on tackling food
insecurity in our district uh and the
motion clearly uh asks for uh food uh
justice uh and food plans to be part of
the climate change action plan of the
council so to be an in integral part
of it and um and actually also uh to
have um food food Justice policies
including accessibility to uh fresh food
embedded in the South warer local plan
so I think um the motion will be uh has
been referred to cabinet so I'm looking
forward to uh come and see the debate at
cabinet thank you councelor Kump you
want to come come in yes I think there's
lots of things here that obviously from
in terms of Economic Development um and
supporting local businesses I think you
know Farms could be behind the list and
potentially some bid from the climate
change fund to help them adapt to the
changes obviously we've had the wetest
February in 258 years I've got the
flooding portfolio at the county
Rosemary so I could say I've been
deluged with emails but we won't use
that point will we um but I think that
yeah we can adapt um and again if you
want us to help I think with climate
change planning and I'm sure the leader
of the council if will agree that if you
want us to help Lobby in terms of
accessibility to to fresh fruit and
vegetables and making it affordable I do
think we are starting to do these things
like the wonky vegetables in and fruit
you know and I think that that is really
good and on sometimes I think they taste
far better than the other ones so
again it's it's supportive I think we do
need to be clever like I said we do need
to adapt and I'm more than willing to
help help and canc did I need to go now
I've got to go to this far consultation
that I'm doing in shipston so many
apologies and we'll catch up soon so
thank you for that no thank you for your
contribution councelor Crump much
appreciated and
uh safe journey okay thank you cheers by
bye councelor Petrovic you want to come
in at this stage and then yeah thank you
just lastly um I wanted to con that we
have obviously uh Stephen and Ed Z in
the room and we just heard a
presentation about the climate Hub in in
town so I think this is really a great
opportunity to bring some of those um
findings and share the the work that
we're doing on food with the with with
town and and the community so I think if
we could collaborate on how we could
present that and and potentially know if
there is um in the future opportunity to
bring a food kind of Central Food Hub in
in Stratford uh to see whether we can
utilize their space as
well thank you I think you open
invitation I think you've got um a
flavor of the fact that we're all very
supportive we'd like to help like to
work with you um obviously you would
have to work with our officers uh I'm
happy to to offer any help that I can
give uh and uh what we'll have the
slides a couple of slides from you but
we you know we we'd like to be able to
um you know have an update as to how
it's progressing and uh please get in
touch with us and make sure that we know
what you want um to help you with the
with the project if if we can you know
need if you need anything from us please
do get in touch and uh good luck with
that I'm really looking forward to it
okay you very much thank you okay thank
you very much indeed for your
presentation really
appreciated um moving on to the next
next item if that's all right with
everybody um it is to discuss the
accreditation of hydrotreated vegetable
oil and this will be for Ellie to update
us yeah so I think it was um agreed that
we would just run past the accreditation
of the H fuel that has been proposed for
use of the RCB Fleet past the climate
change panel so just to kind of update
you really on what I have to hand from
um our waste provider when Poli contract
provider sorry um I know there's
concerns around the use of palm oil the
sourcing of the fuel that we'll be using
is very clear that they do not support
the use or sale of palm derived HBO they
will only Supply iscc verified waste
derived product into the market it will
be fully rtfo accredited and will have
an rtfo certificate and we like I say
will be derived from 100% waste products
it's also worth noting that the the rtfo
um legislation was updated in January to
provide stronger um protection of
biodiversity through the sourcing of any
kind of biofuel whether that be HBO or
otherwise um to put stronger owners
basically on the fact that there is a
risk when we consider any form of land
use change what the kind of land that is
being changed is primarily used for
primarily occupied by so just to kind of
provide some um reassurance really that
we won't be using any palm oil in our
RCV Fleet it will all be as strongly
sustainability accredited as it can
be and also um if it comes from Europe
then the European um protection is
actually even stronger than the the the
Westminster protection um it's that has
been upgraded but um can I make it quite
clear that not only um should this be
from a waste derived SEC that secondary
um materials uh rtfo uh provided
accredited uh supplier but that it
should be part of a an ongoing strategy
so that uh for that for the contractor
to uh as M as other uh mechanisms come
about other Technologies come about uh
that are suitable at the moment electric
vehicles for example are not suitable
for the to cover this rural area uh the
batteries are just not strong enough or
big enough we've had there's been two
trials there was a trial in witch Haven
uh there was a trial in another Council
and they're they're not strong enough at
the moment but there are other
Technologies coming around um that um
are being developed and I know
organizations not only like senx and
various other organizations are testing
a wide variety of Alternatives and I
think if we use this as a way of making
sure that um that that that is being
considered by the contractors as to the
and exact that exactly what other
councils are doing which a and I know is
is doing this as an ongoing strategy but
there are other councils um that are
developing their strategy with their
contract is in exactly the same way uh
so you know it it's there this priority
is waste vegetable oils RTF uh o fo
accredited and as part of an ongoing
strategy uh is the uh is the way that
most councils uh that are operating this
field are going uh counselor Rock oh
counselor Stanley yes first and then
coun Lauren was before me yeah councelor
councelor Stanley First thanks Nigel
councel Ro sorry and chair um I was just
wondering so from somebody who doesn't
have much of the background of H H Fuel
and obviously I've seen a lot um going
on discussion wise between between
everybody in the council um what first
because some to clarify what rtfo means
and then would it be would it not be
beneficial to the council to try and
find a supply of H fuel that comes from
the UK using green hydrogen because
surely that would then have that impact
for lower lower emissions because if
we're then having air miles to bring
over or ship shipping miles to bring
over this fuel it's that's then adding
to a CO2 emission surely that's that's
just my my concern really I hope hope
that makes sense if not I can go over it
again thank
you yeah the rtfo is renewable transport
uh fuel obligation uh and as as Ellie
said was updated in January um and the
rtfo equivalent in you in Europe is even
stronger and has has has been updated so
uh whe it could be Europe it could be uh
UK sourced or it could be European
sourced but they would if they have to
follow the rtfo or the um the I can't
remember what they accredit there's two
standards one for UK and one for Europe
um that the the UK one is Ian something
I can't remember the number but there is
a an accreditation uh standard to which
it has to be provided um to ascertain
and make sure that it is from waste
materials waste vegetable uh or animal
derived you know from uh it could
be we we're talking about bofs that are
that are hydrated vegetable ORS but I do
know that some people use it from abots
for for veget um animal fats as well um
that that can be used in the and the
reason why it is being used is because
it can be dropped into um to replace
diesel straight away without any
adaptation and it is of interest to most
people most people don't know that if
they go to their um their um fuel you
know to fill up their car now from the
uh petrol station there's already
biofuels in the diesel and in the petrol
um as as we speak uh it's already it is
already being used uh to different
levels some of them 5% some some of them
10% and again that's been upgraded in in
recent years uh so that that that's of
that's of interest to uh we've got um
councelor Parker do you want to come in
at this stage just just just briefly
chair thank you very much I I feel like
a bit of an interloper or or gay Crasher
um I mean to be neither um it I think um
when I heard um uh the the previous
speaker talk about um uh embodiment of
she she was referring to embodied carbon
within the fuel and and and how much it
is it would be great I think just uh
kind of to be plain speaking if we could
get biffer to to tell us you know what
is the source to pump footprint o of the
fuel and and you know this is this this
is not like a pack of dogs hounding
anyone down you know this is this is
supportive
uh to to make sure that um uh we
understand where we are and what we're
doing and I'd be very grateful thank you
yeah there's there there are already uh
quite a few research papers that are
that are on this including U senx which
does the research for government and it
did it they did the research for this
Council and War District Council on
electric vehicles for example um they
have a they have all that information
but there are others as well uh uh
Imperial College London has has done
some work because because they moved
their boilers on and they did the
research before they did it so there's
quite a bit of research around but
councelor Rock do you want to come come
in yeah yeah thanks very much and in
fact it it comes uh following on what
councelor Stanley uh and um sorry my
brain's gone out my head but previous
speaker just said um I can't see the the
boards from here but um
uh the debate at the budget really was
about the the background information now
that was a budget meeting where we were
talking about the whole thing but there
was quite rightly questions being asked
about this detail and um the officers
just read out a sort of
statement uh and uh you chair provided a
lot of information verbally I'm just
wondering if we can collect all that up
together with any information we can
glean from biffer and possibly put an
information sheet together that's got
this sort of factual
reliable um authoritative information
round to counselors to say we are we are
listening to these questions that are
being asked and um you know the
questions are not being H in a pack of
dogs we we're you know we've thought
about all these things on the cabinet
we've asked all these questions we've
asked biffer to go away and do it we've
asked officers for this a reassurance
we think we've got it all I wondered if
we could collect it up in some way and
put it possibly in into information
sheet or in some other form possibly
these minutes would suffice I don't know
but I I I I I think we we look for a
document that addresses all these points
that are have been made in some way that
that gives that Assurance I don't what
you I don't know what you think about
that chair um yes indeed um so there's I
think there's about 50 councils now have
gone through this procedure so must be
um quite a lot of um you know
documentation around um and I don't want
to put a lot more weight on on Ellie
warrren um but um or other officers but
I'm it would be it would be beneficial
for counselors to know uh just how many
councilors councils run uh use this
material and um the the the legislation
that has come from government the
legislation on rtfo accreditation uh and
and um you know just a little bit of
factual correct factual information and
councelor Parker yeah a biger pardon
thank you uh chair uh I I I I agree
about not burdening um uh our our own
offices excessively uh and we were uh at
one stage teased with having biffer come
in uh and maybe uh these are the people
who should be uh having their feet held
to the fire and and maybe they should
produce this brief briefing document uh
expounding the benefits of the fuel
they're going to sell us yeah yes indeed
and and what what I think would be of
interest with biffa would be to know
their strategy uh for transitioning uh
because one of the things that they do
have is a climate change officer I I
know that they employ and it would be
useful for them to be able to outline uh
how they see their vehicles
transitioning over the next 10 years for
example um or what other M what are
other vehicles they've tested elsewhere
and why some some vehicles are not
suitable at the moment but might maybe
in five to 10 years time um you say they
will have a lot of that experience
because they are contractors to many of
these other councils as well and um they
surely will have had that experience
with um with with the testing other
vehicles Council hatch and it would be
good to know from them that there's
there's enough Supply and if if the you
know if Supply became an issue what
what's the what's their Str exactly and
the one the one benefit is that it can
be Blended because that's what's in our
Four Courts we've got 5% or 10% in in
current uh petrol and Diesel uh
depending on the standard of of petrol
or diesel uh but it would be absolutely
crucial to know that we've got that
there is enough Supply uh and what would
happen if there wasn't enough Supply uh
but that's why we've got to have a trans
position strategy um that they you know
because we can't but we can't we can't
stay on fossil fuels um you know we've
just got to find a way forward that will
take us away from fossil
fuels okay I hope that is useful
councelor perella do you want to come in
before we wind up yes I just would like
whether we could have an action um out
of this discussion and I don't know what
what is the uh where is the best Forum
but maybe as an action we could invite
Bea uh the port older for environmental
services and the head of ser of
Environmental Services to come and
present to us about um
HBO maybe the climate panel or um you
know another Forum where we can invite
all all counselors as well I mean we are
moving we are moving forward on this now
but uh it is always useful to keep keep
the information uh flowing uh councilor
Rock uh yes uh I think
um first I want to apologize for having
a senior moment and not remembering
Duncan's name but um uh I I
think as was said a a coordination with
biffer who presumably they're using this
stuff Elsewhere for them to put some
sort of document together an information
sheet I think that's what we we probably
need because I would like to allay the
fears of those other the counselers that
had reservations about this with a
factual document as you said chair and
without us spending hours and hours and
Ellie can't do anything else um but if
presumably Biff have got this
information and we can top and tail
it I'm possibly I'm thinking of an
information sheet but um there may be
some other ways of doing it so I don't
know if we can ask officers to go away
and do that coordinate with um Biff
produce such a document and um then we
this this panel or the cabinet can
scrutinize that document as we go
forward certainly as we um we really do
need an update from viffa about the
contracts anyway uh regularly uh and
this would be we we'd need to have an
update on that uh and um and for for
them to show show us uh not only are
they delivering the contract that you
know about Recycling and collecting
waste Etc but but that they are
genuinely thinking about how they will
transition their vehicles okay uh at
that stage I don't unless there's any
particular questions uh I think we've
got an action which is to uh as part of
the negotiation with biffa uh that we
get some information from them uh and um
and some actions about um about their
transition uh and what their strategy
will be there and I think um that will
be very very useful to
everybody okay thank you very much
indeed uh any other questions that does
anybody
have in which case uh I
think is that the end of let me just the
Urgent business do we have any urgent
business that we anybody wants to bring
forward to us no thank you very much and
thank you very much indeed for your time
for your attendance and I look forward
to working with the the people from
Wells the war show War University
wellsborne campus uh on the on the food
strategy I really do and you know yeah
please if if eer can be of any help at
all let me know okay bye
bye okay thank you all
bye